الهم الوحيد الذي يشغل حكومه نتنياهو هو
سحق الديمقراطيه فقد خلصت ميزانيات الصحه
والتعليم من اجل تمويل اقامه جيش من
البلطجيه وميليشيا خاصه
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم وسط جدل محتدم بين
الحكومه والمعارضه حكومه نتنياهو تقر
تمويل انشاء الحرس الوطني المقترح من بني
جزير وزعيم المعارضاي ينتقد الخطوه ويقول
ان الحكومه قلست ميزانيه الصحه والتعليم
والامن لتمويل جيش من البلطجيه واصفا سلم
اولويات الحكومه الحاليه بالسخيف قصف
اسرائيلي يستهدف مدينه حمص السوريه وريفها
يقع خمس اصابات في صفوف العسكريين وطهران
تعلن مقتل ضابط ثان بالحرس الثوري في
الضربات على ضواحي دمشق يوم الجمعه متاثرا
باصابته وتتوعد بالرد ورغم الصمت
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو يقول ان ما سماها
الانظمه التي تؤيد الارهاب خارج حدود
اسرائيل
ستتكبد ثمنا باهظا نتيجه ازمه الجفاف
الحاده التي ضربت البلاد السلطات الروسيه
تتخذ جمله من الاجراءات للتحكم في مخزون
المياه الذي انخفض الى مستويات غير مسبوقه
حيث لجات الى قطع مياه الشرب سبع ساعات
يوميا في كل انحاء البلاد ومنع استعمالها
في بعض المجالات ومعاقبه المخالفين
الرئاسه العامه لشؤون الحرمين تقول ان عدد
قاصدي بيت الله الحرام من المعتمرين
والزوار بلغ تسعه ملايين
و357 الف مصلل ومعتمر خلال الايام العشره
الاولى من شهر رمضان المبارك مشيره الى
تنوع الخدمات المقدمه للزوار من توزيع
عبوات زمزم والكتيبات فضلا عن تقديم
التوعيه الرقميه وخدمات التطويف
الى اللقاء